desde hace cinco siglos los mineros
repiten la misma rutina para extraer la
plata del cerro rico de potosí pero la
histórica mina boliviana que en el siglo
17 fue un motor de la economía mundial
se desmorona por dentro y ha perdido la
cúspide existe el miedo pero qué
qué podemos hacer porque necesitamos
llevar el pan del día a nuestra familia
yo tengo cuatro hijos la policía ha
reportado la muerte de al menos 10
mineros en el cerro rico este año para
protegerse miguel hace un rito dedicado
a la imagen del tal como
acostumbran los mineros bolivianos
mejoren las condiciones de vida y su
golpe si los minerales
desde el cielo son visibles los
hundimientos en la cima de la montaña
por no proteger el cerro rico la unesco
puso en 2014 a la ciudad colonial como
patrimonio en peligro el periodista juan
jose toro es un firme defensor del
patrimonio y ha pedido al gobierno
frenar la explotación descontrolada en
la cúspide no se les está diciendo que
se vayan todas las cooperativas sino
solamente las que tienen operaciones
ilegales en la cúspide esos no pasan de
10 por hacer esas denuncias toro ha sido
golpeado por mineros en el año 2020 con
el ex ministro de minería epifanio
mamani luchan para cuidar el cerro rico
mamani dirige una comisión que busca
soluciones porque los hundimientos y
asuman 19 si no se da una solución
inmediata podría ocurrir una catástrofe
donde podrían fallecer muchos operadores
mineros frente a la urgencia
mamani ha propuesto al gobierno y a las
cooperativas mineras que los obreros
sean reubicados en 90 días y los
hundimientos de la cúspide sean
rellenados con materiales especiales en
potosí salvaguardar el cerro es proteger
el futuro de la ciudad